hi there steve here again to talk about
language learning
uh to talk about myths to talk about
introverts and extroverts
um myths why uh because um
there are lots of myths you hear people
say
that you need a special talent to learn
languages that you can't learn past a
certain age
that you need to have a musical ear
and of course i don't think any of those
things are necessarily true or
even if they were true to some extent it
really wouldn't matter and by the way
i'm picking up on a theme that i covered
in a blog post and i'm going to put a
link to the blog post here in the
description box so that any of you who
use these videos for your
english language learning you can then
read
sort of on the same theme at my blog
so you know you can't learn past a
certain age well i don't know if i'm a
proof that that that's not the case but
even if i'm
not as good at learning languages as i
was 30 40 50 years ago even if my
neurons are running a little more slowly
so what that doesn't prevent me from
learning languages it doesn't prevent me
from having the
the pleasure like i spent the day
building a deck listening to farsi not
understanding much of it and enjoying it
all and then i was able to sit down and
go through some of that
and uh
who cares if somebody 50 years younger
is better than me
again this this business about you know
you have to have a musical ear i lived
in japan for nine years the japanese are
fabulous singers uh every time i went to
a you know a karaoke place and i had to
sing i mean
the foreigners were the worst singers
always the japanese are great singers
but that doesn't make them good language
learners necessarily because there's so
much else that goes into language
learning it's got so little to do with
the musical ear
uh
you know
talent maybe some people are better than
others some people are better at golf
than others that doesn't mean that
anyone who wants to can't play golf you
can still enjoy it so none of those
things matter and the same goes for
introvert extrovert you know
uh
some people say you have to be an
extrovert you have to be willing to go
and talk and be outgoing and exuberant
and stuff
and not necessarily because
language learning is about
you know being interested being
motivated believing you can get there
spending a lot of time listening and
reading
engaging people eventually in
you know meaningful conversation
uh spending the time
uh so maybe an extroverted person will
go out there with you know a
limited grasp of the language and just
try out whatever he has or she has and
maybe an introverted person will be a
little more shy a little more careful
but even in our own language introverted
people
don't end up speaking their native
language
more poorly worse than extroverted
people
uh introverted people don't have less to
say
introverted people don't have fewer
interests
so why would introverted people be at
any disadvantage when it comes to
learning a foreign language it doesn't
make any sense to me at all
of course the idea that that you
shouldn't worry about how you sign you
shouldn't feel shy about your language
and that some people can be so hung up
about making mistakes that they're
reluctant to use whatever they have i
mean that's not a good thing
but
someone who's
devoted a lot of time to studying a
language and learning words and reading
in that language and listening in that
language they are acquiring the language
and at whatever time they feel
comfortable they will start using that
language
and there may be some extroverts that
are better than some introverts some
introverts that are better some than
some extroverts it's not a condition for
learning languages so there you have it
a little bit of a discussion of
introvert and extroverts as it applies
to language learning and if you want to
read more on it if you're you know
wanting to work on your english you can
find this
post on my blog thank you for listening
bye for now
[Music]
you